immer wenn der sechs jahre alte geistig
behinderte leon nicht schlafen konnte
machte seinen vater florian mit ihm
einen spaziergang auch mitten in der
nacht ab in den kinderwagen raus an die
frische luft
ihr letzter spaziergang der endete in
einer katastrophe der kleine leon ist
tot aber florian schwer verletzt es ist
ein furchtbarer in rätselhafter fall
dass leona plan glücklich mit seinen
eltern sechs jahre alt von geburt an
geistig beeinträchtigt es ist vier uhr
morgens vater florian abler und sohn
leon sind an der redford promenade am
fluss aachener kitzbühel mit dem buggy
unterwegs dann passiert das schreckliche
das der vater so beschreibt plötzlich
ein wuchtiger schlag von hinten gezielt
auf den hinterkopf ein brutaler schlag
mit einer glasflasche der vater sackt zu
boden und bleibt bewusstlos liegen
anderthalb stunden später findet ein
passant den 37-jährigen mobiltelefonen
und geldtasche sind weg er kann sich an
nichts erinnern dann der schock auch der
buggy samt kind weg wo ist leon
rettungskräfte ziehen ihn eine stunde
später 600 meter vom tatort entfernt aus
dem wasser leon ist tot keine spur vom
möglichen täter eines motivs und keine
klare erkenntnis was in dieser nacht
wirklich passiert ist der vater konnte
noch nicht ausführlich vernommen werden
besonders mysteriös warum ist der vater
mit leon in den morgenstunden auf der
straße unterwegs der 6 jährige leidet an
einem seltenen gendefekt schlafstörungen
gehören zu der krankheit leon wird
teilweise 20 mal pro nacht wach vater
und sohn gehen deshalb oft nachts am
fluss spazieren aber wer greift nachts
einen vater mit seinem kleinen kind an
diese frage stellt auch die ermittler
vor eine herausforderung
und uns zugeschaltet ist jetzt bild
reporter jörg völkerling jörg das ist
eine alpenidylle man kann sich überhaupt
nicht vorstellen dass der nachts
überhaupt irgendjemand auf der straße
ist schilder uns einmal wie ist dein
eindruck von der situation vor ort
ja ich stehe jetzt hier an der redford
promenade hinter mir sehen wir jetzt
gerade wie die der bauhof von sankt
johann in tirol noch die reste dieses
dramas von vor zwei tagen zusammen kehrt
wir sehen dort wären noch scherben die
dort immer noch lagen beseitigt direkt
daneben sind ein paar blumen kerzen an
dieser stelle stand vor zwei tagen der
buggy verlassen und daneben lag
bewusstlos der vater florian a der von
einem passanten aufgefunden wurde und
dann aus seiner bewusstlosigkeit
erwachte und sofort fragte wo ist mein
sohn das war sozusagen die ausgangslage
dann kamen die ermittler man hat erst
mal den sohn gesucht 600 meter weiter
tiroler ache fließt direkt hier an mir
lang und hört so ein bisschen rauschen
später ist eine sandbank dort hat man
den toten jungen dann gefunden und nun
muss man natürlich schauen welcher
mögliche unbekannte ist da vier uhr früh
am sonntag hier unterwegs gewesen es ist
nicht so heile welt wie man sich das
vielleicht ausmalen mag vergangene woche
gab es hier eine schießerei mit einer
jugendbande und der polizei in sankt
johann also man schüttet schon den kopf
das jetzt hier quasi im wochentakt etwas
passiert und die polizei muss natürlich
objektivierbare spuren suchen es ist
wohl eine flasche sichergestellt wurden
aber sonst gab es hier keine spuren die
man irgendwie wirklich ding machen
konnte man wird funkzellen analysieren
man wird gucken ob man hier einen
verdächtigen herausfiltern kann das ist
so momentan die ausgangslage und dass
der ganze fall liegt beim
landeskriminalamt tirol und die haben da
glaube ich wirklich eine harte nuss zu
knacken
wie geht es dem vater liegt der
verletzte im krankenhaus konnte er
mittlerweile vernommen werden
ja der vater liegt im st jahren im
bezirkskrankenhaus er konnte noch nicht
vernommen werden die polizei sagt also
bis auf diese rudimentären angaben
sonntag früh dass er mit seinem sohn der
ihm schlafstörung hatte zur beruhigung
hier lang gelaufen sei und ihm dann der
unbekannte attackiert habe gibt es noch
keine aussagen von ihm gestern war die
obduktion des kindes in der
gerichtsmedizin in innsbruck
todesursache ertrinken spuren aus
solcher gewalt gab es dort nicht es
steht und fällt natürlich jetzt auch mit
der aussage des vaters wo man auch sagen
muss dass sein durchtrainierter
gebirgsjäger er hat mal bei der rtl show
ninja varia teilgenommen ein eigenes
fitnessstudio gehabt bücher geschrieben
also ein durchtrainierter mann der da
offenbar zum opfer wurde
und es ist aber nicht ungewöhnlich dass
er 16 kilometer von seinem wohnort
entfernt hier unterwegs war sei schon in
kitzbühel mit seinem sohn nachts gesehen
wurden und der kleine leon ist ja erst
anfang juli ist er ja sechs jahre alt
geworden er war der erste fall sinn gab
syndrom in österreich und da hatte seine
familie schon geschrieben seine
schwester wird wahrscheinlich schon früh
um vier aufstehen und wachsein und
muffins für ihn backen und man hoffe
dass der leon den tag etwas später
startet also da war schon im prinzip
klang schon durch dass er oft die nächte
zum tag gemacht hat diese krankheit
diese immun störung hat ihm da offenbar
wirklich den schlaf geraubt
gibt es irgendeine spur die die polizei
derzeit gezielt verfolgt
also man appelliert ganz dringend
natürlich erzeugen die sich melden mögen
ob man hier jemand gesehen hat aber wir
müssen uns einfach vor augen führen
sonntag früh es war ein trüber tag es
hat geregnet es war noch dunkel um diese
zeit um 4 da vorne ist ein fitness vaart
das könnte auch ein grund sein kleiner
spielplatz das könnte auch ein grund
gewesen sein warum der vater hier
unterwegs war mit seinem sohn vielleicht
wollte ihm irgendwie eine abwechslung
bieten wenn er was machen will mit mit
seinen händen aber ich glaube die
chancen sind sehr gering dass das hier
über zeugenaussagen aufgeklärt werden
kann das ganze steht und fällt mit der
aussage des vaters und der liegt wie
gesagt im krankenhaus konnte noch nicht
befragt werden seine familie wird
psychologisch betreut
das ist im moment
48 stunden nach diesem vorfall nach
dieser tat die ausgangslage
[Musik]